le débat a été confisqué qu'on visait
d'abord par le blocage assumé de la
nupes qui a choisi d'ignorer les lois de
la plus élémentaire d'essence commune
pour transformer cette assemblée comme
elle l'avait d'ailleurs promis en ZAD
confisquer aussi par un groupe LR plus
que jamais
otage de sa proximité politique et
idéologique avec la minorité
présidentielle confisquée enfin par la
majorité elle-même et c'est sans doute
le plus grave 40 ans qu'exécutif c'était
à vous que revenez la lourde tâche
d'organiser dans le respect et la
transparence le débat démocratique
[Musique]
la motion du censure a été déposée par
un groupe dont le silence a été
assourdissant tout au long des débats et
dont les votes
et dont les votes ne disent rien d'autre
que l'opportunisme de chaque instant
vous n'avez servi à rien vous n'avez
rien proposé vous n'êtes pas travaillé
mais vous êtes content votre seul moyen
d'exister était de proposer une motion
dont vous savez pertinemment qu'elle
n'avait rigoureusement aucune chance de
passer
depuis le début depuis le début vous
êtes inexistant vous êtes une opposition
en carton qui a chaque moment de
faiblesse du gouvernement venait à son
soutien nous ne pouvons pas participer à
la mascara du rassemblement national qui
a passé plus de temps à écrire cette
motion qui a travaillé contre cette
réforme vous êtes de part et d'autre de
ces démystiques les deux phases d'une
même pièce une pièce factice truquée qui
n'a aucune valeur aucune valeur dans vos
méthodes aucune valeur dans vos
propositions avec vous outrances avec
vos hurlements avec vos invectives vous
donnez la possibilité à l'extrême droite
de ce planquer de se faire oublier et
même de vous voler la vedette en
déposant une motion sous votre nez
j'aurais été requise pour l'adoption de
la motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 297 pour l'adoption 89 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée